.
*sie schnüffelt*
Antioxidativ.
Ok, Alkohol ist ungesund,
das braucht keiner mehr zu erzählen.
Aber nur ein bisschen Alkohol,
ein Bierchen hier, ein Weinchen da,
ist das vielleicht sogar gesünder
als gar kein Alkohol?
Zumindest liest man das.
Schauen wir mal die Wissenschaft an.
*Titelmusik*
Willkommen bei mailab,
Freunde der Sonne.
Ich bins wieder, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Wie viele von euch wissen,
bin ich eine Asiatin... Nein!
...die keinen Alkohol verträgt,
weil mein Abbauenzym kaputt ist.
Aldehyd-Dehydrogenase...
*sie stammelt*
Und wenn ich nicht gerade
wissenschaftlich demonstriere,
dass mein Abbauenzym kaputt ist...
Herzrasen, ja.
...lebe ich abstinent,
ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Dieses Weinglas, Freunde, ist...
nur Requisite.
Aber vielleicht
sollte ich mich mal fragen,
ob ich nicht doch
ein bisschen trinken sollte,
aus gesundheitlichen Gründen.
Es gibt dazu
einige wissenschaftliche Studien.
Schauen wir uns mal eine der neuesten
über Alkoholkonsum und Demenz an,
die 2018 rauskam.
Man hat sich hierfür
über 9000 Briten angeschaut,
die sich in den 80ern
dazu bereiterklärt hatten,
an einer Langzeitstudie teilzunehmen.
Alle 4-5 Jahre wurden die Teilnehmer
medizinisch untersucht
und u.a. auch
zu ihrem Trinkverhalten befragt.
Mittlerweile
sind die Teilnehmer alt genug,
sodass fast 400 von ihnen
an einer Demenz erkrankt sind.
Jetzt fragten sich die Forscher,
gibt es einen Zusammenhang
zwischen Demenzrisiko
und Trinkverhalten?
Ja, hier sind die Ergebnisse.
Was ihr hier seht,
ist die "Hazard Ratio",
aufgetragen gegen die Alkoholmenge.
Rechts geht die Kurve
einfach linear nach oben.
Je mehr Alkohol, desto höher
war auch das Demenzrisiko.
In England ist die
offizielle empfohlene Alkoholmenge
maximal 14 Alkohol-Units pro Woche.
Das entspricht 3,5 l Bier pro Woche.
Mit dieser Alkoholmenge geht
ein gewisses Demenzrisiko einher,
das wir jetzt
als Referenzwert nutzen.
Die stärksten Trinker waren
bei einer Hazard Ratio von drei.
Das bedeutet,
das Demenzrisiko war verdreifacht.
Jetzt habt ihr aber selbst gemerkt,
dass die Kurve links
ein bisschen komisch aussieht.
Erst haben wir einen Bereich,
wo die Kurve flach verläuft.
D.h. in einem Bereich,
wo man eh nicht so viel trinkt,
gibt es sich nicht viel, ob man
bisschen mehr oder weniger trinkt.
Doch dann, ganz links macht
die Kurve einen Knick nach oben.
Und das bedeutet,
dass Leute,
die gar keinen Alkohol trinken,
ein erhöhtes Demenzrisiko haben,
im Vergleich zu denen,
die wenig trinken.
Man nennt so eine Kurvenform
auch J-förmige Beziehung.
Weil das eben
ein bisschen aussieht wie ein J.
Und diese Erhöhung da hinten,
die war hier auch
statistisch signifikant.
D.h, es war ziemlich wahrscheinlich
keine zufällige Schwankung.
Für mich als Nichttrinker
heißt das jetzt erst mal: oh nein!
Und natürlich war auch
dieser kleine Knick das Einzige,
was groß durch die Medien ging.
Für den linearen Zusammenhang
zwischen Alkohol und Demenz
haben sich
die wenigsten interessiert.
Nein, es war die Tatsache,
dass Alkoholabstinenz
mit dieser leichten Erhöhung
von Demenzrisiko zusammenkommt.
Das war die Schlagzeile.
Aber Achtung, Achtung!
Ich hab immer noch keine Batterien.
So viel sagt dieser Knick am Ende
dann doch wieder nicht aus,
denn Menschen,
die gar keinen Alkohol trinken,
die muss man mit Vorsicht genießen.
Also statistisch gesehen.
Wir leben ja in einer Gesellschaft,
in der Alkohol
ganz selbstverständlich dazu gehört.
Wenn hier jemand
keinen Alkohol trinkt,
hat diese Person meistens
sehr spezielle Gründe.
Über mich haben wir schon gesprochen.
Ja...
Bei anderen können andere medizi-
nische Besonderheiten vorliegen.
Z.B. Probleme mit der Leber,
sodass sie nichts trinken dürfen.
Oder dass sie früher Alkoholiker
waren und jetzt trocken sind.
Anders gesagt, Nichttrinker
unterscheiden sich von Trinkern
nicht nur durchs Nichttrinken,
sondern auch durch weitere
systematische Unterschiede,
die sie schwer vergleichbar machen.
Das kann man auch
in unserer Demenzstudie sehen.
Die Gruppe der völligen Abstinenzler
waren in dieser Studie
überdurchschnittlich oft Frauen
mit geringem Bildungsabschluss,
mit geringem Einkommen,
die häufig übergewichtig waren,
sich schlecht ernährten
und wenig Sport machten.
Das alles sind selbst Risikofaktoren
für eine Demenzerkrankung.
Warum diese Faktoren
mit dieser Abstinenz zusammenfielen,
das weiß man nicht,
aber so ist die Datenlage nun mal.
Es kommt sogar häufiger vor,
dass es in Studien zu Alkohol
diesen linearen Zusammenhang gibt mit
J-Erhöhung hin zu den Abstinenzlern.
Wo man die Abstinenzler aber
extra rausnimmt aus der Auswertung,
weil sie
so schlecht vergleichbar sind.
Deswegen sind Menschen,
die keinen Alkohol trinken,
statistisch mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Trotzdem ist es nicht auszuschließen,
dass ein bisschen Alkohol
für bestimmte Krankheiten
von Vorteil sein könnte.
In dieser Studie wurden
83 ähnliche Langzeitstudien
gleichzeitig ausgewertet.
Mit insgesamt fast 600.000 Menschen.
Hier sehen wir jetzt was,
was ihr vielleicht auch schon
in den Schlagzeilen gelesen hat.
Nämlich: Teilnehmer,
die mehr Alkohol tranken,
hatten
ein geringeres Herzinfarktrisiko.
Das Risiko
sinkt zwar nicht beliebig tief,
aber bemerkenswert ist es.
Muss ich jetzt doch zuschauen,
dass ich ab und zu ein Bier trinke?
Nur, wenn ich nichts
gegen Schlaganfälle habe.
Denn bei Schlaganfällen wurde
ein erhöhtes Risiko beobachtet,
wie auch bei vielen anderen
unschönen Krankheiten.
Und über die Studie hinaus
weiß man ja auch,
dass Alkohol mit bestimmten
Krebsarten zusammenhängt
und auch mit Lebererkrankungen.
Deshalb ist es nicht verwunderlich,
dass man hier feststellte,
dass Alkoholkonsum mit einem generell
erhöhten Sterberisiko zusammenhängt.
Je mehr Alkohol, desto früher tot!
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt
durch Herzinfarkt,
aber das ist nicht der Punkt,
den man für sich
aus der Studie rauspicken sollte.
Aber vielleicht ist es gar nicht der
Alkohol, also das Ethanol an sich,
sondern irgendwelche anderen Stoffe,
die Gutes tun.
Rotwein soll ja
so einige Wundermittel enthalten.
Darunter ein kleines Molekül
namens Resveratrol.
*sie schnuppert*
Antioxidativ!
Und ja, Resveratrol
hat bisher in Laborexperimenten,
also an Zellen und an Tieren,
ganz schön beeindruckende Ergebnisse
hingelegt.
Als potentielles Mittel
gegen Alzheimer,
bestimmte Krebsarten,
ja sogar als Anti-Aging-Mittel.
Doch wenn man sich deswegen
Rotwein reinschüttet,
bleibt immer noch das Problem...
Ethanol!
Nach wie vor Alkohol und ungesund.
Wobei man auch Resveratrol als Pulver
im Internet bestellen kann.
Aber auch hier
würde ich das Geld sparen,
bevor es nicht klarere Ergebnisse
aus klinischen Studien
mit Menschen gibt.
Aber kann man nicht
irgendwie ausnutzen,
dass Alkohol
bei bestimmten Krankheiten
das Risiko zu senken scheint?
Vielleicht schon.
Erst mal Achtung, Achtung!
Bei allem,
worüber wir heute gesprochen haben,
handelt es sich um Korrelationen
und nicht um Kausalitäten.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst,
was das bedeutet, nicht schlimm.
Es gibt ein ganzes Video dazu.
Aber wenn jetzt Alkohol tatsächlich
gegen Herzinfarkt helfen würde,
könnten wir trotzdem nicht
Alkohol als Medikament einsetzen.
Wegen so unbeliebter Nebenwirkungen
wie Tod oder anderen Krankheiten.
Aber es könnte sich lohnen,
herauszuknobeln,
in welche biochemischen Mechanismen
Alkohol genau verwickelt ist.
Da gibts interessante Hypothesen,
z.B. verbessert Alkohol
akut die Blutfettwerte.
Das könnte auf Dauer
das Risiko senken,
dass Herzkranzgefäße verstopfen.
Wenn man erst mal verstanden hat,
was da genau passiert,
könnte man
einen Wirkstoff entwickeln,
der nicht so gefährlich ist
wie Alkohol,
aber in denselben Mechanismus
eingreift.
Tja, doch was auch immer
man noch alles Gutes
über Alkohol herausfinden wird,
die gesundheitlichen Benefits werden
niemals rankommen an die Gefahren.
Und in dieser Form kriegt ihr
definitiv nur beides gleichzeitig.
Insofern...
Cheers?
Ok, eine Frage
so unter Freunden der Sonne:
Liegts nur an mir,
weil ich keinen Alkohol trinke,
oder findet ihr auch
unseren Umgang als Gesellschaft
mit dieser Droge Alkohol befremdlich?
Mach ich mich jetzt unbeliebt?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Themenvorschläge für neue Videos
sind auch immer willkommen.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag.
Trinkt nicht so viel
und bleibt sicher.
*sie schnüffelt*
Ethanol!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)